SPEAKER: All through
the evolution of mankind,
there has been
this constant connection.
Woo!
CHILD: You can see why
this tree's almost dead.
DIRK BRINKMAN: A lot of things
have happened to it.
♪ (CONTEMPLATIVE MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
SPEAKER 2: When I look out
at the trees in my backyard,
I think about time.
This tree has been alive
-longer than Nona and--
-CHILD: Me?
SPEAKER 2:
Oh, definitely than you.
This is a vine.
It's gobbling everything up.
It's just like there's a war.
GEORGE WEYERHAEUSER: Timber,
it's always been a big thing
in my life,
back to my great grandfather.
I don't know whether it didn't
lead to my kidnapping, too.
BETH MOON: The first trees
I photographed,
I was just drawn to
how fragile they are.
SPEAKER 3: It's called
an internment camp,
but it was really
a concentration camp.
SPEAKER 4: "If I can
bring life to this tree
and have hope,
maybe one day we'll get out."
SPEAKER 5:
My father bought my mother
this cherry blossom tree.
All of the freedom that
he didn't have in the world,
he poured into that land.
SPEAKER: Cold, heat, fire,
volcano.
The tree could die,
or the tree could live.
Be gentle.
SPEAKER: But it's always going
to carry the scar of it.
CHILD: It's coming! It's coming!
SPEAKER: It just builds
on itself with time
to become this.
That's a story.